vous invite à rentrer au coeur de ce
château d'azay-le-rideau l'histoire
d'azay-le-rideau prend ses racines des
11 119 s'il s'appelle ainsi c'est en
hommage à l'un de ses premiers
chevaliers le chevalier ridel et non un
rideau qui entreprend l'édification
d'une forteresse pour des sites destinés
à protéger à la route entre tours et
chinon ce premier château que vous voyez
dernièrement a été détruit lors d'un
incendie en 14 18 un incendie provoqué
par charles 7 afin de déloger les blés
troupe bourguignonne qui l'occupé le
château ainsi que vous voyez derrière
que vous allez voir derrière a été
construit en 15/100 18 mais je vous
laisse le découvrir avec mélanie
traquenard azay-le-rideau un des plus
jolis châteaux de la renaissance
nigérienne dessiné par le trésorier de
françois 1er gilles berthelot et par sa
femme philippe laisse bailly un
quadrillage très fort une verticalité
très marquée par ses lucarnes et ses
bandeaux has et se situe à la fin du
gothique est au tout début de la
renaissance bon grappille un petit peu
là un petit peu là un petit peu là et
puis on se fait son son château à soi et
d'ailleurs vous remarquerez que dans le
val de loire ou qu'un château pourtant
de la renaissance ne se ressemble tout
simplement parce que les interprétations
les architectures les architectes
interprète de manière différente cet
héritage italien et du nord de l'europe
fort de ses contacts à la cour berthelot
embauche les artisans italiens ça donne
cet escalier jusqu alors inconnu en
france
azay-le-rideau nous avons un escalier
rassurant donc c'est un escalier droit
avec un noyau central est une des choses
assez extraordinaire dans cet escalier
du château d'azay-le-rideau c'est
justement la présence de rampes donc un
escalier qui est confortable à monter
avec des paliers donc dès qu'on appelle
des repos à l'époque c'est repose sont
ouverts sur l'extérieur par des grandes
loggia donc on voit ici évidemment l'
influence italienne d'époque aussi cette
charpente en chêne qu'originaire de la
forêt de chinon à l'étagé inférieur la
chambre raffiné de madame laisse bail au
xvième siècle cette chambre était un
véritable espace de vie pour recevoir
manger et même travailler une pièce nat
et de jongh pour réguler la température
à la renaissance on utilisait bien
évidemment des tapisseries pour isoler
chiens les pièces pour les décors et
aussi bien évidemment mais aussi le jonc
très c'est donc ce savoir faire s'est
perdu en france est aujourd'hui le
château d'azay-le-rideau est le seul
château fois où on a ce type de
revêtement mural à en 1529 gilles
berthelot sera accusé de malversations
après sa défaite de pavie françois 1er
de donner une rançon à charles quint
pour sa libération
il ira chercher l'argent où il y en a
chez les trésoriers berthelot devra
s'exiler à metz et n'achèvera jamais
azay-le-rideau pour l'admirer entourée
d'eau il faudra attendre le 19e siècle
[Musique]
nous voici de retour sur le ponton qui
mène à ce magnifique château
d'azay-le-rideau accompagner notre
premier invité jacques buisson qu'at-il
bonsoir merci de nous recevoir
puisque vous êtes au sein de ce château
bondir vous nous recevez dans votre
château que vous connaissez par coeur un
château renaissance plus tout à fait
château renaissance qui dans sa forme
actuelle date delà du premier quart du
16e siècle
même s'il a été remanié par la suite
assez largement pour certaines de ses
parties effectivement nous avons là
château de la première renaissance
française qui est souvent considéré
comme appartenant quintessence de la
renaissance française contrairement à
d'autres fiat au du zones tribales de
l'or c'est vraiment un bijou un de cette
époque là parce que c'est les
particuliers il est tout à fait
considérée comme un joyau et c'est le
terme qui revient très souvent même
comme un diamant taillé comme disait
balzac
effectivement il présente quelques
particularités qui font de ce château
qui font de ce château renaissance un
château tout à fait à part dans le val
de loire
on en a on en a vu un petit peu des
particularités notamment si vous deviez
en choisir une qui vous a marqué moi
évidemment c'est cet escalier à loger a
déjà vers lequel nous progressons là qui
est tout à fait remarquable qui diffère
de notamment de certains escaliers que
l'on peut retrouver dans notre château
du val de loire
mais il ya aussi beaucoup d'autres
choses et notamment le parc et toute
l'eau qui entoure ce château alors
jacques justement prenons un petit peu
de hauteur et regardons des magnifiques
images vues du ciel en drones un des
images où l'on peut apercevoir un
domaine de combien d'hectares jasmin
qu'hector 5 hectares est belle ce miroir
d'eau autour du château
d'où provient cette hausse et c'est une
rivière c'est un c'est une poche alors
c'est landreau qui passe et qui parce
qu'ils passaient à l'origine à proximité
du château
mais des aménagements divers au cours
des siècles ont été effectués notamment
le 19e siècle par les marquis de
billancourt qui ont réalisé ces miroirs
d'eau qui
qui font en sorte que ce château semble
flotter sur l'eau aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup jacques de nous avoir
donné toutes ces précisions
je vous repose à présent de découvrir
les parfums à l'époque de la renaissance
regarder un solide
comment on pratiquait la renaissance
c'est à dire on utilisait des produits à
base de cire huiles parfumées et on se
parfumer comme ça on mettait son doigt
et puis on voulait ce parfum c'est celui
de la reine margot une fragrance composé
d'ambré de musc et de jasmin que nicola
de bari a pu reconstituer grâce au
carnet de comptabilité de la cour
elle utilisait les matières premières et
ensuite les mélanger ça donnait une pâte
et donc s'adonner à parfum solide qu'est
ce que ça reflète de la personnalité de
la reine margot la sensualité
parce que on est dans un parfum
extrêmement sensuelle extrêmement
puissant et le goût pour les choses
originales et personnelles parce que
elle faisait elle-même son parfum c'est
son choix s'est fait à la maison période
de renouveau artistique et
architecturale la renaissance a permis
des innovations sans précédent dans la
parfumerie l'ouverture de nouvelles
routes commerciales
il fut pour beaucoup on va chercher les
matières premières en asie directement
on ne passe plus par venise on parle
plus par le sultan de de turquie on va
directement donc ça c'est ça amène
beaucoup plus de matière première et à
des prix plus accessibles
encore que très cher et puis il ya la
découverte par les arabes de l'alcool et
donc on va commencer à utiliser l'alcool
en parfumerie à partir de la renaissance
de ces nouveautés l'astrologue
apothicaires nostradamus saisie en 15
155 et rédige un traité des phares de
man dans lequel nicolas de bari a puisé
une recette composé d'ingrédients ultra
moderne à l'époque
les oranje qui arrive à la cour de
france à l'époque de la renaissance
ce sont des produits de luxe dont qu'il
met dans le parfum des zestes d'orange
et ce faisant c'est comme s'ils
mettaient des louches de caviar dans un
plat c'est le fin du fin c'est le chic
du chic
une senteur très en cour que la future
reine margot y certainement le privilège
du mais alors qu'elle n'était qu'une
enfant
cerise sur le château se cachent dans
les combles nathalie la charpente en
chêne est une merveille elle vient
d'être restaurée oui tout à fait alors
les combles sont ouverts aux visiteurs
depuis 2011 mais nous avons eu un grand
chantier de restauration de 2014 à 2016
2017 même et les combles ont été
entièrement restauré la charpente a été
mise à nue fait un travail tout à fait
exceptionnelle pour pouvoir permettre à
nos visiteurs de découvrir cette
charpente renaissance d'un genre
incroyable d'un genre incroyable le
comble en usage est dit ici à surcroît
exprime tout à fait alors si vous
observez bien vous remarquerez que la
charpente repose sur les murs et non pas
directement sur le niveau du plancher
ça permet de récupérer un décalage qu'il
ya dans la grande salle qui se trouve
juste en dessous flanc et qui est plus
haute que toutes les autres salles du
château mais aussi donc de ménager un
espace suffisant pour y stocker des
marchandises puisque le comble servent
évidemment de grenier à la renaissance
cette charpente est très rare et elle
date de combien de temps alors cette
charpente est exceptionnel par sa
qualité mais aussi par son âge elle a
exactement 500 enfants elle a été elle
et renaissance évidemment et donc les
bois qui ont servi les armes qui ont
servi à construire cette charpente donc
des chaînes ont été abattus dans une
forêt de haute futaie qui est la forêt
de chinon enfants et le propriétaire du
château d'azay-le-rideau gilles
berthelot avait obtenu de la part de
françois 1er
l'autorisation donc de couper ces arbres
c'était au coeur de l'hiver 15 118,15
119 et elle fut vraisemblablement
terminée aux environs
15 122 apparemment d'accord en 2009
l'unesco a fait quelque chose de spécial
raconte est oui alors l'unesco a classé
l'art du tracé de la charpente au
patrimoine mondial immatériel de
l'humanité
donc notre savoir faire exceptionnel
savoir faire exceptionnel des compagnons
qui se transmettent ce savoir-faire de
génération en génération et lors de la
restauration de la charpente en 2016
2017 les charpentiers compagnons qui ont
travaillé ici ont d'ailleurs découvert
des méthodes d'assemblage qu'il ne
connaissait pas donc c'est aussi un
grand moment à la fois techniques et
historiques
nathalie vous vouliez me montrer quelque
chose à un tableau un nombre des
charpentiers oui alors vous avez ici un
petit tableau qui vous présente le
nombre des charpentiers qui était en
fait un code qui étaient utilisés pour
la préparation des poutres pour leur
assemblage et si on regarde bien
certaines de ces poutres vous pouvez
encore retrouver ses traces tant qu'ils
ont 500 ans et qui ont été faites par
les compagnons pour assembler sa
charpente tout à fait exceptionnel merci
beaucoup nathalie de nous avoir dévoilé
les secrets de cette charpente l'air je
vous en prie merci une séquence
enregistrée cet après midi vous l'avez
compris parce que actuellement nous
sommes dans la grande salle du château
d'azay-le-rideau accompagné de notre
invité philippe bélaval vous êtes
président du centre des monuments
nationaux
bonsoir pourquoi vous êtes ici vos soir
parce que vous gérez le château
d'azay-le-rideau oui c'est un des
fleurons du réseau de plus de 100
monuments que le centre des monuments
nationaux
gr au nom de l'état et nous sommes ici
azay-le-rideau dans un château nous
avons mené une grande campagne de
restauration qui a duré plus de trois
ans et nous sommes heureux de présenter
un fleuron de la renaissance à nos
nombreux visiteurs tout à l'heure quand
on était hors caméra vous me disiez que
vous étiez content de venir nous
rejoindre aujourd'hui à azay-le-rideau
puisque ce château est particulier pour
vous il ya vu beaucoup de rénovations
des années comme vous le dites
alors on voit quelques images
qu'on avait tourné il ya quelques mois
quelques années la restauration a duré
longtemps c'était un long travail un oui
plus de trois ans parce que ça a été une
restauration complète et on a commencé
par le parc puis ensuite les extérieurs
les façades les toitures les menuiseries
et puis on a beaucoup travaillé aussi
sur l'intérieur tout le rez-de-chaussée
a été remué blé et puis cet espace du
premier étage nous avons installé vous
voyez toute une animation des automates
qui retrace les fastes des banques les
de la renaissance
voilà on voit ça devant nous et c'est
une salle renaissance ont pesé sur les
murs il ya des tapisseries là vous avez
confectionner un buffet comme à l'époque
c'est très important pour les 500 ans de
la renaissance de faire découvrir cela
au public
oui parce que au fond on à la
renaissance la plus authentique avec les
tapisseries qui viennent de nos
collections et qui sont purement
renaissance et puis on a aussi un peu la
manière dont l'esprit de la renaissance
s'est prolongée a été réinterprétée dans
l'est dans les siècles suivants et
philippe la renaissance est également
léonard de vinci
on le connaît le génie léonard de vinci
aujourd'hui c'est la fête de la musique
alors avant de se retrouver dans la
chambre du roi je vous propose de
découvrir l'une de ces machines une
machine hybride appelée à la viola
organiste à
si ce jeune homme et merveilles ces
spectateurs à l'aide de son instrument
hybride c'est grâce à leonard raccourci
certes mais de vinci a tout de même
inventé la viola organise sa vie comme
ça ce n'est pas très concret joue la
corde mais lorsqu'il l'a dessinant 14
170 dans le codex atlanticus le génie
n'a qu'une vague idée du son qu'il va
produire
c'est un instrument de musique à mi
chemin entre l'orgue le clavecin et la
viole de gambe
c'est tout chaud tout du piano et
pourtant le rendu est très différent
vous allez voir elles sont toutes
reliées à des mécanismes qui presse les
soixante et une corde en métal contre
larcher en crin de cheval en bleu juste
là
cette boucle de crin qui fait office
d'archers et mis en mouvement par une
grosse poule i elle même actionnées par
le musicien grâce à un levier situé le
long de sa jambe
lorsqu'il marche la roue tourne larcher
au contact du métal et médée sont très
variés des vibrations qui rappelle le
son d'un violon celles d'un orgue ou
d'un accordéon
[Musique]
l'ingénieur est décédé avant de voir
construite et saône et saviola organiste
à il aura en effet fallu attendre 2013
pour qu'un pianiste polonais lui donne
vie et confirme ainsi le statut de génie
de léonard de vinci
[Musique]
nous en avons profité pour nous rendre
dans la chambre du roi dont nous avons
parlé tout à l'heure où nous avons des
automates
on en parlait expliquez-nous pourquoi
c'était important
c'est une commande que nous avons passé
dans le cas de la restauration à deux
artistes pièce zoé est clean qui sont
spécialistes de ces de ces automates
alors ça une double fonction il ya
peut-être un hommage indirect à à
léonard de vinci et au génie de la
renaissance qui ont construit beaucoup
de machines complexes mais il ya aussi
le souci d'émerveiller nos visiteurs
parce que voilà
azé est un château magique et petits et
grands sont contents de voir ces
automates qui ponctuent la visite de
l'ambiance féerique c'était important 1
2 mais les deux arts on va dire la
renaissance l'époque de la renaissance
avec l'art contemporain
oui enfin c'est un art contemporain
assez raisonnable vous en conviendrez
mais je crois que c'est très très
important parce que les visiteurs sont
évidemment des gens d'aujourd'hui
et donc quand il visite un monument
historique il faut bien qu'ils fassent
le pont entre la période évoquée par le
château et puis et puis aujourd'hui et
ses oeuvres font un peu le lien entre
ces deux époques en prenant le meilleur
des deux la restauration avec ces
nouveaux automates a permis à plusieurs
annonces de nombreux visiteurs de venir
en nombre ça augmenter la fréquence
brille beaucoup beaucoup c'est à dire
que en fait si vous voulez on dit
azay-le-rideau c'est le bijou des
châteaux de la loire
mais avant la restauration car les
visiteurs venaient il était un peu déçu
parce qu'il trouvait le le bijou un peu
ternie ou défraîchi alors que grâce à la
restauration
voilà il n'ya plus de déception et il ya
une ambiance vraiment féerique et
j'espère qu'ils seront très nombreux à
venir cette année à l'occasion merci
beaucoup monsieur b laval d'avoir et net
de d'avoir été notre invité je vous
propose de découvrir un groupe
tourangelle une formation tourangelle
devenu en trente ans une référence de la
musique renaissance regarder
[Musique]
si la renaissance et ses 500 ans doulce
mémoire fête ses 30 ans trois décennies
pour jouer cette musique ancienne à
travers le monde cette formation racines
tourangelle a choisi pour son
anniversaire de s'installer le temps
d'une soirée au grand théâtre de tours
[Musique]
répétition avec des invités complices
claire diterzi ou encore l'étonnant jean
françois zygel venus d'iran musique
toute son admiration à cet orchestre
hors norme
hélas son directoire moi je suis comme
beaucoup de musiciens compositeurs
surtout étant donné ma génération on ne
connaissait pratiquement rien à la
musique avant bach et donc j'ai
découvert tout cet univers chatoyant
rythme et coloré et festif c'est une
musique de la danse et musique de ma
joie c'est une musique dans kenyon part
d'improvisation ce qui faisait vraiment
très plaisir
c'est presque le le jazz du 16e siècle
en quelque sorte
si vous pensiez que la musique
renaissance est un peu poussiéreuse
détrompez-vous et riche graves parfois
mais aussi ludique
de la musique qui parle souvent de son
temps qui chante l'amour et financier la
musique de la renaissance par rapport à
la musique médiévale c'est une vraie
révolution
en effet avec un accroissement des voix
avec une expansion et extraordinaire de
la musique et la prochaine révolution
qui interviendra c'est la révolution
baroque mais il ya comme ça deux siècles
extraordinaire de foisonnement musical
avec des immense compositeur qui sont
évidemment contemporain des génies qu'on
connaît tous ce qui sonnait
qu'entreprend de léonard de vinci
évidemment m'étonner l'est aussi dans
tous les grands peintres italiens du 16e
siècle ou des grands personnages que ça
soit erasme que ce soit rabelais que ce
soit françois pons mixant réduite mais
je pourrais en parler pendant des heures
c'est une période incroyable des
instruments anciens qui deviennent
tellement moderne
une renaissance qui permettra la musique
de s'ouvrir vers le monde qui donnera
des bases aux sonorités contemporaines
[Musique]
c'est la fin de cette page spéciale jt
de la renaissance au château
d'azay-le-rideau la semaine prochaine
vendredi prochain nous serons
accompagnés de toute l'équipe bien
évidemment mais également de denis guen
est meilleure à chambord et comme c'est
la fête de la musique aujourd'hui je
vous propose de se quitter en musique
avec l'une des guides du château cécile
souquet
[Musique]